alright guys we're here with Tom I'm
super excited about this episode because
Tom spends all day researching learning
and trying to share facts we know that
there's plenty of just nonsense out
there in the crypto space so hopefully
we can have a pretty sober conversation
about research and kind of how you see
the world yeah thanks Tom
absolutely all right so you were doing
research before you ever got into crypto
so maybe start with your background and
what you're doing before yeah sure so I
went to Rutgers Business School
graduated there and started working on
Oppenheimer on their cloud and
communications Equity Research team I
was under a great boss you know a lot of
modeling a lot of white papers and
eventually we wanted to figure out
whether or not blockchain and aetherium
in particular would be disruptive to the
cloud companies we covered AWS Microsoft
Azure etc so I wrote a hundred page
blockchain white paper they're not easy
to publish on the sell side but you know
I'm glad I did because it made them look
like thought leaders and they are and I
fell down the rabbit hole completely and
left about two weeks after that was
published and opened up by institutional
crypto research shop and I research all
day yeah what would what's the name 51%
and where did that name come from
51% attack and it was so developers get
it and then the point 72 ish people also
get it it's kind of like a name in a
number got it it makes a lot of sense
alright so let's talk about what equity
researches in the non crypto world right
a lot of people probably don't actually
know what that is so maybe just explain
you know who the types of people who do
this research why are they doing it and
who are they selling it to and what do
those people use it for yeah sure so I
mean equity research traditionally is
meant for sell-side institutions to sell
to hedge funds pension funds
institutions stuff like that to be a
legitimate source for great information
great calls and actionable content doing
that in crypto is a little differently
because in equity research there's only
three ways you make money
the first one is management access the
second one is models and the third one
you know could be events NDA's stuff
like that or an on dale road shows and
crypto is a little bit different because
management access is free everyone has
access to these developers you could
tweet them you can get access to them
but what we don't
is we don't have sources in crypto where
a crypto fund or an institution can go
and say hey I found this great source
for models and content and we can
actually use this to make decisions on
because my take is no institution or
crypto fund has going their investment
community with medium post and saying
hey you know I have this great info
because they can't call that person up
and ask them about their model so my
goal is to basically put out great
content great reports actionable
research that people can actually use to
invest on make calls and get involved
and on the equity side so non crypto who
are the people who are normally taking
the information being that research
that's being created
traditionally mm-hmm so that would be
generally hedge funds pension funds you
know some VCS not really but mostly
mostly iPhones so capital allocators
your investors yes right and and what
are they doing with it it's this
research sometimes they're using it to
learn they're using it to actually make
investments in trade what's kind of the
the distribution it's a great question
so and they'll use it to learn they'll
use it to get ramped up on ideas they
don't want to spend ten hours you know
on Twitter and medium and reddit trying
to figure out what this new platform or
DAP is they want to read a ten page
report they want to know everything
there is to know and they want an
opinion and then after the fact you know
inch or quarter or whatever then you can
publish updates this is what's going on
here's an actionable call this token got
crushed
you know maybe now's a good time to
answer stuff like that and normally in
the non crypto world right so forget
about crypt there for a second but in
the non crypto world what are the types
of things that that research gets
published on are we talking specifically
companies are we talking like industry
trends are we talking just a complete
deep drive deep dive on an actual
industry a whole host of things awesome
questions so it really depends on the
analyst you work for it okay so in the
past I worked for a very progressive
tech analyst so we would publish white
papers on the 5g nu nu cloud
technologies you know anything from ng
pawn to to datacenter technology we
would cover everything and then within
those white papers we would establish
companies and calls that we thought
would be applicable and would benefit
from these industry trends so to me
crypto and blockchain is a huge
district trend we have to figure out the
specific companies and plays and
platforms that we can actually be
involved with the drive value so that's
what I try and do all day long is to
find those companies and most of my time
is spent finding the companies that are
not religious
and that's not that easy to do sometimes
got it in so let's flip to the crypto
world right because I think that there's
some parallels right so I'm asking about
the non crypto world but but in the
crypto world that there's a whole host
of nuances and kind of things that don't
exist in public markets for example
right so you described one of them with
access to management but maybe walk me
through you know one of the reports that
you've already created and it just kind
of do a high-level overview and then we
can walk through how that actually got
created and kind of step by step you
know what goes into these reports yeah
sure so I mean one of my favorites
report I've done is on Maker Dao it's a
stable coin project that's totally
decentralized andreessen horowitz bought
I think six percent of their token
supply so we're seeing institutions get
involved already but one of the things I
looked for is I looked for you know
what's gonna drive the next trend in
twenty-ninth well before you do that
what is maker down
okay so maker Dow is a stable client
project there's two different coins dai
Dai is the stable coin pegged to a
dollar hopefully it's it's stayed at its
peg so far due to numerous stability
mechanisms that are built into the
platform and then maker
MKR is the governance token so that's
the token that allows people to vote on
upgrades to the platform whether that be
you know new collateralization ratios
for new assets or just changing the
protocol overall so maker Dao is an
interesting project the reason I
targeted it was because I think stable
coins are going to be a huge use case in
2019 and people say oh why would I want
to invest in a stable coin is going to
be pegged to a dollar there's no upside
there there's two upsides the one upside
is potentially in maker and maker doubt
because that's a platform that's growing
and the other growth area is if you have
a viable stable coin you can drive
immense use cases that don't have the
problem of bitcoins volatility or
at there's volatility because you know
pom campaigns pays employees in $1,000
stay in $1,000 tomorrow people know what
they're getting paid and the use case
for that is in salaries gain
smart contracts assets everything can be
used with a stable one you're one of my
favorite people in cryptid to talk to
you just because you go into these
projects and you do these super deep
dives and you know most people in the
industry probably have some
understanding or could describe to you
hey you know X project does a B and C
right but you've really spent the time
to understand the pros the cons talk to
people who are working on it talk to the
naysayers etc maybe it with maker Dow
let's talk through you know what did you
do to become educated on that space yeah
it's a great question so I mean it does
take a lot of work I mean I'm not on
Twitter and I'm not looking at one tweet
to make a decision here on what I should
you know potentially research it's a lot
of work it's you know you have to start
with the white paper you have to make
sure that this project makes sense does
the utility token here or the token
actually have a use case I mean that's
one of the major questions you have to
hit on because if not why are you even
researching it second thing is you have
to go through everything read it you
have to go through token supply with the
ICL to the developers or founders own
too much is the inflation too high then
you have to go through everything from
the governance does this token actually
allow me to make changes or have a say
in the platform because 99% of the
tokens out there 99.9% don't have real
governance the only ones I can point to
that do or like tezo's and that's they
still haven't even voted on anything yet
and then after that you have to go
through all of the different aspects of
whether the platform itself can actually
drive value in the future so with make
or Dowie obviously thought that a stable
coin could but my problem is I don't
want to invest in tether because it's
gonna be at a dollar forever hopefully
and there's transparency issues I want
to invest in something that's going to
drive real value in the future and
enable new use cases and so who did you
talk to you right so once you read the
white paper do you immediately start
talking to the individuals who are
building the project do you talk to
maybe other analysts or people that you
find on Twitter talking about it how do
you kind of work through that web of
people that are in and around the
project awesome question I reached out
directly to Rouen Christensen the
founder I said rune I have 35 questions
I need answers to them you could either
help me out with this or I can make my
own assumptions here
and you know I reached out to rich at
the Maker Dell Foundation as well he
helped me out and then I'll talk to
other people you know you could talk to
Joe Schmo and read it because there's so
many people out there with such great
info mm-hmm
there's zillion different ways you can
learn in the space but there's real
value in compiling all of those
disparate sources into one source that
people can go to that has real analysis
and boils it all down and so as you talk
to these folks you know if you were a
reporter for example and somebody gave
you a statement you would have to go and
validate that statement right it's
either true or it's not true so they say
to you you know hey we have 37 employees
or a reporter would go and make sure
that they have 37 employees right how
far does a research or normally go in
terms of validating the different
statements that they hear obviously from
the company I'm assuming there's much
more kind of emphasis on the validity in
accuracy versus like that random person
on Twitter who says something and maybe
you go check it out or maybe you don't
it's a great question and the weird part
about it is a lot of these you know
quote-unquote random people on the
internet Twitter they have a lot of
great info of course you know they have
a lot of great info I mean because
they're people that are also doing the
work but it has to be presented in a way
that's institutional grade but as for
the platform itself like a maker Dow I
went online I made sure that these
collateralized debt positions that make
our our backs are live you know I made
sure that it's peg has been somewhat
maintained it's buried a little bit due
to some problems earlier on but those
have been addressed but you have to go
through everything because if there's
anything that's wrong with it there's no
you know over lying body that's gonna
take care of this for you it's Wild West
yeah
what's interesting to me I think is in a
lot of these projects right you're
basically asking somebody to say what
are you doing right how is it supposed
to work how far are you along in
building what you want to build but then
there is an element of like we don't
know about the future right so they
think that they're gonna continue to
still build things and and it'll kind of
go in this rosy picture we obviously
know that everything will change
what's the balance in your mind between
you know when you're writing a research
kind of saying hey here is what the
world looks like today and what's built
and what's working and how that looks
versus you know here's what this could
become and then here's also like the
really bearish case as well like how do
you balance writing those two things
it's a that's a great question
the best way I would word this is you
need enough data that you know that the
platform today is sound enough to make
sure that they can get to that future so
an example is 0x they're building
decentralized equality protocol on
theory em you could run different
decentralize exchanges using it
different real layers build their own
platforms now what people don't realize
today is the token self has zero
governance functions you control nothing
by bonnet oh and except being able to
pay fees but the point is we net we have
real ayres on zero X I think over 40 of
them at this point that are actually
transacting tokens in real time you can
use 0x and put it on your website to
allow tokens to be exchanged in real
time so I know that the platform and the
protocol is working today so I'm okay
with not having governance features now
because I know there's a roadmap but the
point is I know that 0x protocol works
now so I can force see it and project it
out on what I think it will become if
there was no real layers on 0 X or you
know it was all a white paper and hope
then I'd be like alright you know maybe
this isn't legit so you definitely need
enough at stage 1 even though we're
early on to validate that it can be
successful in the future mm-hmm
ok ensue in traditional research you
know let's say you're covering a company
for example you're an analyst and you're
gonna cover Amazon right you kind of do
your initial research hey here's what I
think about the company a lot of times
you're putting buy sell hold type you
know recommendations on it and then
there are periodic updates right it
obviously helps that in the public
markets there are these you know
earnings reports that come out you know
each quarter and so you have a chance to
get on calls and ask the management
different questions how does this work
in the crypto world right like what is
the periodic kind of updating of the
research where people can say you know
we wrote something three months ago six
months ago twelve months ago and we
write we were wrong the project has you
know made a left turn and it's doing
something else how do you think about it
well I definitely don't miss earnings on
equity
research that was 5 a min at midnight
but you know it's it's a good question
in crypto it's it's two things the first
one is vague the first one is it can be
quiet for a project for awhile so you
have to make sure you're actively
looking for did they hit this milestone
are they actually executing are their
competitors gaining traction you have to
look for that but it's also a lot of
random events that pop up like we sign
this contract we have this partnership
Civic announced this new partnership is
this legit so it's all it's a lot of
reaction in some cases to what's
happening in the market which is you
want to be proactive but there's just so
much news flow in crypto and so much
interaction that you have to just be out
there every day looking for updates and
reacting to it got it in let's talk
about some of the projects right so I
haven't really talked too much about
different tokens or models on the
podcast and frankly it's because you
know I really don't have an opinion
right but I think that you're the
perfect person to run through maybe the
top ten tokens and we can discuss kind
of how you look at them what you like
what you don't like what you think is
important for people to pay attention to
etc if that works yeah no I mean to be
honest Bob you know we're so early in
this space that I try not to be biased
on whether or not a project is you know
legit or not legit for sure but we'd be
remissed by not we have to make calls
and we have to be honest with people
about what we think because we're not
helping people by hiding facts from them
or our opinions we have to give them
opinions that they could make decisions
or not because if you look at coin
market cap a year ago I don't know what
number it is but a lot of those coins
didn't exist or they're gone by now so
we have to be really we got to be
opinionated
well yeah into you know look this is not
financial advice right this is more of
you know the merits of the technology
the developers and frankly your personal
opinion and understanding right and so
this stuff can change tomorrow like a
developer you know the lead developer of
a project could leave and immediately
the outlooks completely different I mean
I totally so let's start with Bitcoin
what um what what's your take their pros
cons what you think about it I have
nothing wrong with Bitcoin I think it's
great do I think it's gonna replace the
US dollar in the next five years
absolutely not I don't think Fiats going
anywhere anytime
it does Bitcoin have serious problems
it's facing absolutely you know Jimmy
song can yell all you want as Twitter
I'd love to talk with them but you know
Jimmy give me ten applications or
companies being built on Bitcoin you
know other than thoughts or writings
about things that will be built on
Bitcoin mm-hmm but do I think Bitcoin
solves a zillion problems absolutely
it has a great monetary policy it's
fixed we don't know how much money the
Federal Reserve's printing we know
exactly what's going on with Bitcoin we
know the supply schedule we know who
owns it it's global for people that are
in horrible countries like Venezuela it
solves a zillion problems for them it's
nothing wrong with Bitcoin I think it
gets uh how it gets too much flak in the
space what what is the kind of bearish
case right so if I asked you hey five
years from now Bitcoin completely goes
away and didn't work what would be the
number one reason why you could see that
happening it's a good question you know
one of the things I think about with
Bitcoin is and people sometimes even
myself when I first start in crypto kind
of argue Bitcoin has to change it has to
grow as a currency or store value I
don't think it has to change
I think the point is that it doesn't
change like it's hard to change that's
the point we don't want it to be easy to
change we want this to be a stable and
rock solid as we can so for people that
argue between Bitcoin aetherium or
others they have to separate in their
mind what they're talking about Bitcoin
is supposed to be hard to change let's
keep it the same let it be a store of
value
mm-hm and then build up the stack layer
- mm-hm
but people really have to segregate
those things you know what to answer
your question what do I think it killed
Bitcoin Bitcoin can kill itself Oh
interesting let's why would you say that
like what does I mean I I don't think
anything is gonna replace Bitcoin as a
store I don't think Bitcoin cash is
gonna kill Bitcoin or litecoin you know
charlie lease sold all of his holdings
that's a terrible sign for a company or
protocol but the only thing that's gonna
kill Bitcoin is itself and what I mean
by that is it's going to be either the
developers leave the story changes or
people go to a new version of Bitcoin do
that so what I mean Bitcoin cult itself
I mean people will go to a fork if
anything but I don't think fiat currency
is gonna kill big one yeah well and it's
when these things where you know I I
think a lot about with Bitcoin
specifically everyone wants to pit
fiat currency versus this decentralized
digital currency right and I think less
about like 1v1 and I think more about
coexistence and allowing people to have
two options and you individually can
choose which one you think is more
appropriate for your specific use cases
your specific needs and that doesn't
mean that one's better than the other it
just means that it fits your solution
yeah I told you I mean think about the
world in which Bitcoin replaces fiat
money I mean that means that you know
the government has no control over us
like that all sounds great and
everything but who's paying you're cops
and firefighters
you know who's paying to get the garbage
off your streets and pay the Public
Works people are you just gonna donate
to them you know people don't think
about that dystopian if the world ends
tomorrow and Bitcoin wins we're all dead
anyway I love it all right let's talk
about aetherium because I know that you
are you're quite bullish on it so walk
us through pros cons and kind of what
your view is yeah theorem is an awesome
platform my opinion I was akin to it or
I was drawn to it because ice cover AWS
in part and Microsoft Azure so platforms
you can build on and one of the things
that I loved about aetherium was Vitalik
you know the guy was just such a forward
thinker he put out great research and
you know the other thing I really liked
about him was he was very receptive to
the problems he wasn't like Dan Larimore
at EOS just calling people out you know
he was like submit research to me I'll
review it and I'll send you back 20
pages of comments so not not myself but
other people that have worked with them
so that's why I loved the founders focus
you know of course with other people but
what I love about aetherium is I love
that we're actually seeing applications
being built on it and we're actually
seeing use cases you know whether that
be maker Dow with the stable coin being
built on it whether that be 0 X with 3
layers being built on it for
decentralized exchanges we're just
seeing in my opinion the most vibrant
and strongest developer community that
we have in the space I published a
report on serenity if their names
upgrade that's coming out the first part
of that is going to be hard fork in
mid-january but serenity is a new
upgrade that has a multi-year timeline
people are saying 2020 to be honest that
I don't think
gonna happen within two years what does
especially with developers but that's
gonna bring new changes to the platform
where we're gonna have sharding which is
instead of one blockchain you have a
thousand 24 block chains all under a
beacon chain or a public beacon shine
however you look at it but that's going
to enable a ton of new use cases because
what people would understand is layer
one
I don't think layer one should be scale
like the base blockchain protocol
aetherium that should be decentralized
have tens of thousands of nodes be hard
to change but when you move up the stack
to layer two you should have things like
plasma and real scale that people can
build on
so decentralize layer 1 scale layer 2
and I think that's where we get all the
great use cases out of and with a
theorem I think we get that through
serenity
what's your biggest concern as to why a
theorem could completely disappear I
have a thousand concerns my job is to
look at all the concerns right but the
biggest concern is not in my mind
competitors it's can the developers
actually execute and I don't know if
people you know like aetherium
surrounding update this isn't like a
tweak to the code or like you know chain
you know control fine change this word
to that word they're rebuilding the
entire foundation of the protocol they
have to make sure that this works
because if it doesn't work you know your
base layer I don't people kind of
overlook us a bit all the applications
built on top of a platform are all
subject to the base layers governance if
something happens to a theorem space
layer everything built on top of it is
affected not only the aether in your
coin base wallet but maker tau zero X
all the applications can get messed up
so my biggest concern is whether or not
they can make this huge transition I'm
confident they can because they have the
smartest developers in the room in my
opinion but uh we're gonna have to say
XRP oh god I'm gonna have the XRP army
on me if we go too far into this I wrote
a deep dive on RIP 1xrp and I also had
one of their a guy I'm really fond of
Weist wind Wiest wind my podcast - and
he's developing a tip bot which I
thought was awesome he could tip people
in real time went
using XRP but am i invest in XRP no no
way why because it's run because I have
a fundamental problem with exer P it's
owned by retail customers who have no
use case for the currency XR P is
supposed to be used by banks
multinationals for remittances Global
transfers and payments
there's no use case for retail investors
to own X R P so I don't understand the
bull case for them there's also numerous
problems with it like the first 30,000
blocks of the chain are missing ripple
makes all of their money selling the
currency ripple controls 60% of the
nodes and they control the unverified
list or the verified list that decides
who is a node there's just too many
problems with it in my mind I'm not
saying ripple or XR P is bad they
actually have a use case people forget
like global money and payments of
transfers that's a use case but are
there better alternatives out there that
are truly crypto yes so your take if I'm
hearing this correctly is that ripple
meaning the company that has technology
that is trying to sell it to banks is
positive and is real technology that
could go compete with Swift at some
point in the future etc didn't it sounds
like the issues is really around XRP the
currency that is used within that for
all the reasons you just described long
rip a short excerpt B got it okay I
think that's fair writing I think is
quite a few people who'd agree with that
but you know what there's a lot of
people that will disagree with me on
that and that's fine of course my job is
to have an opinion and to share that
because if I'd be remiss if five years
go by and I didn't share my real opinion
well in and I think that part of
research right especially given what
you're doing is to say here's my opinion
and here's the work I did and here is
why I believe what I believe agree right
and so somebody could say hey I disagree
with your opinion but I understand how
you arrived at that opinion right and
that's still a win for you now that's
that's a great point and in the
institutional world that's how it works
you sit down from an investment kin of
your Vista manager and they say hey you
know what Tom I love your report a trip
or X or P or a theorem but hey I
disagree on these points but I get
directionally where you're going on
crypto Twitter
everybody is binary I love this I hate
that and in my mind that's not how the
investment world works you hate
something to a degree you like something
to a degree if things change that stake
then you can move on it but you have to
keep that gray area down
I love aetherium but if I see the
developers flailing like when I saw the
one Dex come out with these private
meetings that was a concern to me
because it's supposed to be transparent
and open the developers came out and
they addressed it whatever which was
great but you have to be critical on
every event but you have to have a gray
area on what how the degree to which you
like things are ate them mm-hmm got it
tether tether wouldn't touch it why
because you will always have the
transparency issue you will always have
a problem of does tether have X amount
of US dollars in their bank or not that
will never be transparently solved my
opinion ever we're always gonna have to
wait for quarterly statement and if what
if they don't share it you know when you
go on maker now you can see the smart
contracts and you can see the the amount
of money or the amount of ethyl acht up
in real time you know there's like 2% of
all that they're locked in maker Dow
right now smart contracts backing dies
stable coin it's transparent it works
and people know exactly how much is out
there mm-hmm got it and then you
recently published a report on privacy
coins yep
what what was kind of your take there Oh
God highly technical could you cover
four of them if I remember correctly
right yeah
privacy coins is is a is a tough area to
get your head around and the first the
the first understanding is why do we
even eat privacy coins right and people
I think forget that bitcoin is totally
transparent you know like you give me
your wallet pump I'm gonna go on and
explore and track all your payments back
to everywhere you know with privacy
coins the goal is to hide that off you
skate it hide what you own so people
can't track you so you can you know if
you want to donate to a political party
why should anybody have to know that I
donate it to it things like that there's
a there's a lot of use cases for privacy
coins but it's a highly complex field
and it's dominated by two coins Manero
and z cash both go about it differently
monaro goes about it with three main
items shielded transactions ring
signatures you know
technical items that kind of how do I
describe this there's like 11 people in
the room and one of them did a
transaction we don't know who it is Z
cash is the next generation of privacy
coins in my opinion they use ZK snarks
which is a highly complex field where
you don't actually have to reveal any
data but you can verify what actually
happened now
each has its problems of course Monero
is obviously you know less technically
secure I think but the point is their
entire base of transactions is private
on the network z cache has visible
transactions and shielded transactions
and a shielded transactions only make up
around 15% of transactions currently so
the base is smaller today but the point
is we're not investing for today
remember tomorrow we want the most
secure coin and that's Z cash my opinion
or from an era got it into as part of
this right you know what you just
described is a quick summary of a lot of
work that you did in terms of the
technical understanding of what people
are building how do you wrap your head
around it right there's the way I think
of crypto and I'm fascinated by people
who are doing research and really
looking at this stuff who are not
technical these are highly complex you
know theories and software that's being
written is your approach to read first
and then go talk to people building it
and ask all your questions or like how
should people who are sitting at home
saying you know what I've seen Manero
right I hear people talking about it I
want to go learn about the technology
what's like the way for them to attack
that learning that's a that's a great
question and in my mind the majority of
people you know leatherby public
equities or stocks or whether you know
with Jim Cramer say or whether it be
crypto are always gonna look for a you
no pun intended here trusted source of
where they're going that information and
I'm not a coder I'm not a dab developer
so when I looked at Manero and Z cash I
said you know what do we have any
examples of this stuff actually being
messed with you know and with Manero we
did you know we had a report where two
hundred thousand transactions became
visible they addressed the problem did
that percent drop from you know eight
percent transactions of 50 I don't know
but the point is we have to look for
tangible real word real-world data on
these systems falling apart
z cash has you know several items that
are also wrong with it like they had a
trusted set up at the start of their
currency where six people were involved
in this if these six people kept part of
their you know shard they can print Z
cash at will so we have to be real
cognizant of the real-world problems
that we're seeing because I don't think
ever the majority of people are ever
going to look at the code of these
things you know how many people look at
the white paper and then how many people
look at the github like it's got to be
way down and listen you step yeah yeah
what um is there a piece of technology
that you think is really promising or
important that maybe you know most of
the people listening is won't be aware
of or won't actually understand the
importance of encrypt Oh mm-hmm
I mean to be honest I still feel like a
lot of retail people aren't looking at
aetherium you know everybody's stuck on
Bitcoin and that's great that's that's
awesome
you know bitcoin is you can't knock it
but we have to look at where's this
technology taking us and where are we
going and we have to invest in the
platforms that are going to be building
the next generation of that you know can
we be wrong in aetherium maybe but will
you gain a ton of insight and knowledge
on decentralized platforms in crypto by
understanding aetherium
absolutely mm-hmm without a doubt got it
and so I guess you know as you look out
over the next 5-10 years right what's
your take in terms of the things people
should be paying attention to what are
those themes that you know again maybe
that they're not making investments
based off of but just as somebody who's
interested in crypto you know these are
the important kind of trends to follow
yeah it's a great question the first one
is probably stable coins in 2019 I think
that stable coins will enable a new
generation of interaction between people
because a stable currency solves quality
of the issues so is a stable coin sexy
no but is the applications that can be
built on it sexy absolutely you know the
other thing would be security tokens
gonna be a huge topic in 2019 2020
can we securitize a building absolutely
is that fun and exciting absolutely not
but can pomp own 1% of that building
across the street by buying a token on
coin based that's fun that's interesting
and then you have the derivatives market
build on top of that so I think people
have to understand that the base layer
that everyone's focused on building now
these base layers they're not fun and
exciting sometimes they're really boring
but we need them to enable the fun use
cases whether that be decentralized
Facebook or whether that be dividing up
the Yankees into $5,000 token slots all
of that stuff is enabled by perfecting
the infrastructure layer and the stuff
built on top of it nobody's gonna be
able to predict when that comes but it's
impossible without the stuff we're doing
today I see what about people that you
end up seeing you know on Twitter reddit
exception like information sources that
you think are maybe not as well-known as
let's say kind of the mainstream media
type stuff yeah that's a great question
there's a zillion like I'm on medium
every day and I you know I rarely ever
see the same author because there's so
many people publishing so much data I'm
surprising you with these questions
because I want to know what off the top
of your head when I ask you best sources
yeah here's the two or three that like
stick out in your Mike's I mean those
are the the really good ones yeah what a
non-answer
now there's there's a lot of sources but
to be honest I try not to look at
opinionated sources until I have my own
problems with an idea or a platform I'm
not looking at anybody's medium post
anybody's you know thought topic or
thesis or a reddit post until I
understand the dynamics of the token
because I don't know whether I'm
spending an hour reading something and
the guy might be wrong in his first
sentence you know where I might not
agree with it so you have to start with
the foundation then go to opinion people
you know then get your fun stuff
exciting stuff about what you think can
happen mm-hmm it's funny because you
know we spend a bunch of time as many
people know listening that you're
talking these institutional investors
and a lot of them always say to me hey
you know look this is interesting to me
I'd love to learn more about it you know
send me all the information that you
have and then can you recommend a couple
of sources of information where you know
I can't learn more and the first time
somebody ever asked me that I jokingly
was I told my partners
as I said what am I supposed to do be
like go follow whale panda like you know
bully esq on on Twitter and you know I I
think highly both of them but just the
institutional pressures like wait who is
that totally right but you know one of
our goals here is we don't you know the
idea is do we meet Wall Street in the
middle or do they meet us so you know
they have to meet us in a point they
have to get Twitter they have to get
ready they have to start looking at
these sources so that was just another
data source but it's alien to them
because they've never used it before
this is an Edgar and SEC filings and
Yahoo Finance this is Twitter reddit and
medium you know you got to get on that
that's a really interesting idea if
there was like an Edgar meets Twitter
right and and you basically have the
validators of the system being all of
the Soudan anima secound son like the
crypto oh geez hopefully we gotta get
there that would that would get out of
control real fast
oh yeah and we'd have a lot of fighting
like those crypto cruises people go on
exactly alright so let's do a round of
rapid-fire questions before we wrap up
here if you had to get if you had to say
what the most important company in
crypto was what would you say consensus
ooh
hands-down really smartest guys in every
room you you think that consensus is the
most important company in crypto most
important hands down 1,200 of this well
after layoffs - 13 % yeah people
building 50 spokes that people don't
even understand how valuable they are
they're building all the back and
infrastructure they're building all the
new use cases they're built for
aetherium for the-- well to be honest
people think consensus is a theory
Enfocus I don't think they're gonna be a
theory and focus forever okay that's
interesting why because in my mind their
systems integrator they're gonna build
on whatever platform makes sense today
that's aetherium tomorrow by B Theory MX
I don't know but I think would they ever
build on Bitcoin god now it that would
be a super unforeseen development in the
crypto world if consensus ended up
building on a Bitcoin well all I would
say is if you have 50 companies and
they've all decided to add a thousand
people over a thousand people
and they haven't built on Bitcoin yet
why would they start tomorrow they
obviously have a reason to not build
them yeah they're gonna believe for
whatever this year course but I mean
beliefs are fine but these are engineers
that are deciding where and where they
cannot build and they've decided not to
I mean yeah block stream to go on
Bitcoin of course if you could wave a
magic wand and change any one regulation
or improve it what would it be I
probably have the SEC put out actual
regulation and real guidance instead of
being vague and having everybody
question their every move regulation is
not bad for the space it's great people
want to know how they can build but they
don't know because it's Hinman's
comments so then Hester fiercest
comments and then questions and are we
regulating this or that we need real
regulation that's that's the goalpost
I love how every time one of the
commissioners talks like a conference
they all caveat it with this is my
personal opinion this is not represent
the SEC or any of the other
commissioners right and it's smart on
their part right like they've you know
if you asked me would I rather them do
and and proceed the way that they have
versus maybe how other jurisdictions
like you know China or whatever have I
would much actually rather the way that
American regulators have handled this
right they haven't been overly
heavy-handed they've really put in time
to try to learn right and and they say
look there's a bunch of stuff we don't
know we're trying to figure it out and
we want to kind of stay true to our
mission of protecting investors
providing fair and safe markets etc
there's all kinds of complaints people
have in there of how that's being
applied whatever but but I do think you
know it's interesting to see the I guess
you can call it dissent between the
commissioners and how they look at
technology you know this technology
specifically but but they've done a
pretty good job I think most people
would agree with it
they've done a great job but there's two
things here I mean one is there's a lot
of investors and consumers over there
that have been you know screwed over by
horrible pump fish icos right yeah of
course but on the other hand of this I
don't think the SEC will ever seed
crypto or blockchain to another country
we did we're not giving up the fight on
5g to China right why would we give up
the fight on crypto to another country
if the SEC in my opinion knows that if
they're heavy-handed or they don't
provide real you know regulation it'll
go to another country they don't have
jurisdiction shopping yep what's the
most important book you've ever read
um I love fooled by randomness oh what's
that
favorite book ever and I seemed to leave
basically argues against or NASA seemed
to leave I don't know how to pronounce
his name he's on Twitter he's an awesome
guy it's just all about chance and all
about randomness you know it argues that
your neighbor that's a millionaire might
not be a millionaire because he's smart
but maybe because he was lucky so his
whole thesis is you know get an industry
that's resistant to change so we're
probably in the wrong one I usually want
to ask the regulation question people
talk about all kinds of things but one
that's popular is the accreditation laws
right and I always say you know I don't
know I know a lot of dumb rich people
yeah that's a perfect example just got
lucky yeah or they or somebody they're
related to was smart right exactly
very cool all right so I usually ask one
non-encrypted question everyone knows
about the aliens we've got to just admit
that aliens are real but I'm gonna ask
you a little variation so you know I
would ask you know do you think there's
alien pets or animals but instead
because you're a researcher and you
spend a lot of time focused on how to
learn about things what would be your
approach to find out as much information
as you could about whether aliens are
real or not it's a great question what's
the process for people to go learn about
aliens well I mean there's just so much
information out there I feel like it
would be worthless to go online and read
all conspiracy Stewart there is I would
probably find should we just go to space
and see what's up I mean we have to talk
to musk or us or you know the ambe's us
and go on one of their Rockets but what
I would do is I would try and find any
astronauts on the moon and I would find
them in a closed room and I would ask
them face-to-face do aliens exist and
you think that they would have an
opinion just given that they spent so
much more time thinking about space and
galaxies and absolutely yeah my uncle's
my green a singe enira he'll put a fall
on the moon and you know he always told
me his conversations with the astronauts
or conversations that they would never
share with the media it's crazy and
today it is spaces is something that has
just fascinated me because it doesn't
matter what we actually do there right
there are going to be so many people
that never believe it's true yep right
now I spend way too much time thinking
about ty
in space and galaxies and the multiverse
and you know there's a thousand
different universes where me and you
were sit on different sides of the table
right now like it it's wild to think
about how small the earth is in the
grand scheme of the world and then how
small we are on the earth it's just like
oh man what is going on that's that's
the whole point of the podcast actually
all right so I end each one with letting
the guests ask me a question what what
one question do you have for me what do
you want to see in a year from now go
ahead shoot people come on now they're
like ready I don't like this is my what
do I want to see one year from now with
Bitcoin honestly I think that what I
call the Bitcoin fundamentals just
continuing to grow right and so it's
less about like some big qualitative
dream or utopia of like I everyone's
using it whatever I think if you take
today's point in time right so recording
this in December of 2018 and we look at
to December of 2019 hash trade continues
to grow remember of waltz continues to
grow number of transactions continue to
grow overall transaction volume
continues to grow right you know
lightning continues to grow in terms of
all of its data points to me I've come
to peace with Bitcoin specifically is a
very long-term project that the beauty
of it comes from the slow methodical
nature right totally I mean there's
plenty of people who have higher time
preferences etc right but I've pretty
much just said to myself you know this
is the one project we're moving fast and
breaking things right that you know is a
really bad thing right and to the design
is in such a way that if we get this
right it could be it could be the most
powerful computing power or the
computing platform in the world now
there's a whole bunch of things that go
wrong between now and then right some of
the things you mentioned other you know
just simple a software bug raised great
you know a great example could just all
go away but but I do think
time and those fundamentals continue to
grow or you know kind of the most
important thing in my opinion